[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يصلوا القدس
ويقول ان مسؤوليه التهدئه تقع على عاتق
الطرفين الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي
روسيا تحذر من انها على حافه الحرب مع
واشنطن وبولندا تلمح لامكانيه تزويدك
بمقاتلات افسته عشر
تفجير انتحاري في باكستان يوده بحياه
العاشرات اغلبهم من الشرطه والام يصفه
بالعمل الارهابي
المعارضه التركيه تستعد لمرحله ما بعد
اردوغان وتدعو لاعاده النظام البرلماني
بدلا من الرئاسي
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من جوله وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه الى الشرق الاوسط وصلت
الى اسرائيل قديما من القاهره لدى وصولها
للمطار بتصريحات مقتضربه اكد فيها على
ضروره لتخفيف التوتر بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين مشيرا الى ان هذا الامر
مسؤوليه الطرفين كما اكد لينكن انه سيطرح
خلال زيارته ضروره التوصل الى حل دولتين
وذلك لانهاء الصراع
قبل ذلك اجرى الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي محادثات مع بلينكنج بالقاهره
الرئاسه المصريه قالت ان بلنكن نقل للسيسي
ان بلاده تعول على التنسيق الحثيث مع
القاهره لاستعاده الاستقرار وتحقيق
التهدئه واحتواء الوضع ما بين الجانبين
الفلسطيني والاسرائيلي السيسي اكد على
اهميه العمل بشكل فوري في اطار المسارين
السياسي والامني لتهدئه الاوضاع في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه والحد من اتخاذ اي
اجراءات احاديه من الطرفين من جانبيه قال
متحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه بان لينك
الناقشه مع السيسي سبل خفض التصعيد بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
وفي مؤتمر صحفي جمعه مع نظيره المصري سامح
شكري اكد لينكن على الدور القيادي الذي
تلعبه مصر في المنطقه حيث ادعى الى تعزيز
سبل الشراكه مع القاهره في المرحله
المقبله
مصر بترخص جهود للتعامل مع اكثر المشاكل
لتعقيدا في المنطقه وعملت على تعزيز الامن
والسلامه والرخاء وهو امر مهم وحيويه
سيكون هناك المزيد من التعاون بين مصر
والولايات المتحده في المسائل التجاريه
والاقتصاديه والتواصل الى نتائج ملموسه
تشمل خلق فرص عمل وتحسين المعيشه يجب
القول ان مصر لعبه دورا مهما لمعالجه
الوضع في ليبيا وعقد الانتخابات وجعل
الليبيين يتمتعون بحق اختيار قيادهم
تحدثنا ايضا عن السودان وانتقاله الى
الديمقراطيه وتشكيل حكومه تلبي مطالب
الشعب وهو ما يعبر عن دور مصر الكبير في
مجال الامن في المنطقه اليوم نعمل مع الق
المصريه ضمن جهود المشتركه لتخفيف التوتر
بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
كانت حاضره بقوه خلال هذه المباحثات
واهميه لتحقيق الاستقرار لمنع اي نوع من
التصعيد
وايجاد الاطار السياسي الملائم
للتوسل الى حل دائم وشامل وعادل للقضيه
الفلسطينيه على اساس مبدا حل دولتين تاكيد
انه همم التطورات الاخيره هي تطورات مخيفه
همم نعمل على احتوائها وتوصل الى اعاده
التهدئه واعاده العمل على همم مراعاه
مصالح كل الاطراف وايضا استقرار المنطقه
من جانبيه حمل رئيس الوزراء الفلسطينيه
محمد تاشتيه حمل اسرائيل المسؤوليه
الكامله وايضا المباشره عن التصعيد الحاصل
في الضفه الغربيه والقدس مطالبا دول
العالم في مستهلي جلسه الحكومه اليوم الى
اداره التصريحات وزراء الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الداعيه لحمل السلاح ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني
في الحكومه الاسرائيليه التي دعا فيها
هؤلاء لحمل السلاح لارتكاب الجرائم بحق
ابناء شعبنا وان يتم التعامل مع تلك
التصريحات العنصريه على انها اعتداء على
الانسانيه وعلى كل القيم الحضاريه ان مجلس
الوزراء ينظر بخطوره الى القرارات الصادره
عن مجلس الوزراء الاسرائيلي المصغر ضد
ابناء شعبنا وخاصه اهلنا في مدينه القدس
المحتله ويعتبرها مخالفه للقانون الدولي
والاتفاقيات جنيب وهي تعكس عمق الازمه
التي تعيشها حكومه الاح هل والتي تحاول
تصديرها على شكل مزيد من عمليات القتل
والقمع وفرض العقوبات الجماعيه وسياسه هدم
المنازل واطلاق ايدي المستوطنين
الارهابيين
اهلا بك زياد اسمحلي ان ابدا بتصريحات
لينكن وان كانت مقتضربه هل تحمل اي جديد
لا تحمل جديد
الهجمات التي سماها الهجمات القاتله في
القدس وما الى ذلك طبعا قضيه ايضا الحديث
عن حل الدولهتين هذا كلام تقليدي في
العقدين نسمعه من الولايات المتحده من
الادارات المتعقبه لكن بدون مشاكل لان هو
طبعا يلتقي من يمين نتنياهو رئيس وزراء
اسرائيل يلتقي همم لقاء الان فرديا معه
وبعد نحو ساعه من الان سيكون لديهما ايضا
مؤتمر صحفيه للحديث همم بطبيعه الحال في
اسرائيل يدركون بان تم ارسا توتر في علاقه
نتنياهو باداره
وربما ما يزيد هذا التوتر نوعا ما وجود
ايضا وزراء همم يصفون بالمتطرفين في حكومه
نتنياهو همم الولايات المتحده كان توضحت
بانها لديها صعوبه في التعامل مع هؤلاء
همم وبال الان همم الموضوع الاول بات وهذا
خلافا لرغبه نتنياهو قضيه منع انفجار
الوضع تماما في العلاقه الفلسطينيه
الاسرائيليه همم طبعا بيدا سيطلب من
اسرائيل عدم اللجوء الى خطوات يمكن لها ان
تؤدي الى فقدان السيطره على الميدان لكن
لا تاثير لوزير خارجيه امريكا على هذا
الموضوع كثيرا في اطار على العمليات
الفرديه التي نشهدها عمليا
القرارات الاسرائيليه هل هو قادر هل
نتنياهو ايضا قادر لانه اخر شيء سمعنا حتى
بنسير عم بتطلع بتصريحات تتحدث عن اعدامات
بالكرسي الكهربائي وغيره تصريحات فقط
للاستهلاك الاعلامي وتهديدات فقط ام انها
يمكن لها ان تطبق بالفعل وتمرر
بين كبير عدى مشروع قانون اعدام منافذيه
العمليات ولا يتحدث فقط للاعلام سيطرح على
الكنيست للتصويت اغلبيه لدى الائتلاف حتى
في المعارضه الاسرائيليه هناك احزاب قد
تدعم هذا التوجه ايا كان هذه التصريحات
طبعا الامريكيون يعرفون ان جزءا منها قد
يكون للاستهلاك المحلي في شارع اليمين في
اسرائيل لكن بدون تشك عمليه همم لينكن
يضعوا يده في اللعبه القديمه ذاتها اداره
الصراع اداره الصراع بدلا من حله لان حل
الدولتين لا يبدو منطقيا ولا مطروح ان
الان في ظل هذه الحكومه بعد ومن ثم ميسون
علينا ان نشير الى ان باستثناء بيدن كل
ال- واداره الامريكيه تقريبا تواجدت هنا
في الفتره الاخيره سوليفان والايضا
ويليامبرز الرئيس موجود هنا والان بلينكن
والربما الوجود شق فلسطين في الزياره
بحد ذاته يعتبر رساله لاسرائيل بان التحرك
في الاتجاهات المختلفه يتطلب تخفيضا للعنف
على الصعيد الفلسطيني
وعدم همم انهاء حاله دولتين على الارض اذا
ما ارادت اسرائيل مساعده امريكيه في توسيع
دائره التطبيع مع الدول العربيه او حتى ان
ارادت ان تكون واشنطن الى يمينها في
مواجهه عليها ان تغير ربما الاداء فيما
يتعلق الفلسطيني
جزيلا لك
في باكستان تحدثت مصادر طبيه هناك عن مقتل
لما لا يقل عن 32 شخصا واصابه 147 اخرين
في الانفجار الذي هز احد مساجد بشاور شمال
غربي باكستان وفق السلطات المحليه وكاله
رويترز نقلت عن مصدر طبي باكستاني قوله
انه معظم القتلى فيلم الانفجار
من رجال الشرطه
مراسل العربيه افاد ايضا من جانبه ان
الهجوم ناتج عن عمليه انتحاريه وان اصابع
الاتهام تشير الى حركه طالبان باكستان
التي اعلنت سابقا انسحابها من الهدنه مع
السلطات اسلام اباد
المزيد معنا من اسلام اباد مراسل العربيه
عبد الرحمن المزيني اهلا بك عبد الرحمن
اخر المعلومات المتوفره حول هذا الحادث
الارهابي
نصف ساعه من الان ااا وصل رئيس الوزراء
الباكستاني برفقه قائد الجيش ووزير الدفاع
ووزير الداخليه الى المستشفى الاكبر هنا
في مدينه بيشاور لعياده همم ضحايا هذا
الهجوم وصفه رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني شباب
شريف بانه هجوم ارهابي
انتحارينا فده انتحاري
الحصيله المتوقع ان تزداد مع مرور الوقت
هنا خلفي اقف الان امام الحي التابع
للشرطه والذي وقع فيه الهجوم اليوم همم في
صلاه الظهر اليوم همم حتى الان تقوم بعض
فرق الانقاذ بمحاوله رفع الالقاب همم لجزء
من المسجد الذي تهدد احد جدرانه همم هناك
همم
نحو خمس اشخاص لا يزلون حتى الانقاض ويجري
طيب يبدو ان هناك مشكله بالصوت عبد الرحمن
تكرر باختصار
انني الان اقف امام الحي الذي استهدفه
الحي الذي التابع للشرطه الذي يضم عدد من
مقر الشرطه وقسم مكافحه الارهاب هنا خلفي
كما ترون هناك حاجزان امنيان لابد لاي شخص
اراد العبور الى داخل هذا هذا الحي ان يمر
عبرهما والسؤال الذي يطرح نفسه الان هو
الذي تعكف اجهزه الامن الباكستانيه للحصول
على جواب له وهو كيف تمكن المهاجم
الانتحاري من الوصول الى داخل هذا المقطع
الذي الحي الذي يشرف عليه جهاز الشرطه
والوصول
طيب الصوت يتقطع على كل المحاول العوده
اليك عذرا هناك مشكله بالصوت عبد الرحمن
المزيني مراسل العربيه من اسلام اباد شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات
[موسيقى]
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
سيستغرق الامر دقيقه
يلا نبي نصحصح نبي الاكل ابداع جهزي العده
وافردي الخبزه ودهن اللبنه والحين وين
العجينه حط اللبنه والزعتر رشيه ايوه
بالضبط اغرفيها شويه سمان الله
والخيار قطعيه ايوه غمسيه يا سلام عليك يا
فنانه كل فخر صنعت في السعوديه لبنه
المراعي الفاخره طعمها يبيض الوجه
اذا ما تبيني انتقد نفسي اقول والله انا
ممتاز انا ماني ممتاز كيف ممكن نحنا نقنع
الاجيال بهذا الموقف الغريب يعني حسبي
الله هو ايران في لبنان
خلينا نقول انت اللي هتقود الرحله اليوم
بس تعال شوي شوي من المطبات
ويطلع منيح
هذه الجماعه دوليه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه نكمل حول
تداعيات الحرب في اوكرانيا حضر نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسيه
على حافه الحرب مع الولايات المتحده بسبب
عدم تجديد معاهده الحد من التسلح واعتبر
رياض بوب انه لم يعد هناك داعل للحوار مع
اوكرانيا او الدول الغربيه بعد قرار
الولايات المتحده تزويد كيف بدبابات
ابرامز واعتبر ان واشنطن هي المستفيد
الاول من الصراع بزياده مبيعاتها من
الاسلحه لاوروبا
الهجوم الروسي على واشنطن لم يتوقف عند
ذلك الحد بل قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
موسكو نجحت بوقف البرامج البيولوجيه
الامريكيه في اوكرانيا حيث اجرت واشنطن
تجارب تتعلق بفايروس نقص المناعه البشريه
في اوكرانيا بحسب الدفاع الروسيه الدفاع
الروسيه اشارت الى وجود شركه امريكيه
متخصصه بفيروسات كورونا تعمل باوكرانيا
منذ عام 2015
وقامت باجراء تجارب على انتقال فيروس
كورونا من الحيوان للانسان بحسب ما اوردت
الدفاع الروسيه
من جانبي قال رئيس الوزراء البولندي
ماتيوزو مورافيكي ان نقله مقاتلات افسته
عشر او طائرات اخرى الى اوكرانيا ممكن
المسؤول البولندي
رهن هذه الخطوه بالتنسيق مع حلفاء الناتو
الاخرين كما حدث مع دبابات ليوبارد 2
الالمانيه واوضح انه جاري التنسيق مع
الناتو حول جميع الاجراءات لتعزيز قوات
الدفاع الاوكرانيه بما في ذلك تسليم
باتريوت الى اوكرانيا من جهه اكد رئيس
مكتب رئيس بلد مارسلنسكي اندريما اوكرانيا
تتلقى اشارات ايجابيه من بولندا بشان نقل
مقاتلات متعدده الادوار اليها
لم تتوقف دعوات الدعم العسكري لكيف على
الغرب فقط بل امتدت ايضا الى سؤول حيث حتى
الامين العام لحلفي شمال الاطلسي يا ناس
ثلثمبرج حتى كوريا الجنوبيه على زياده
دعمها العسكري الاوكرانيا ردا على تزويد
كوريا الشماليه الاسلحه لروسيا متابعه
الروسيه والتي تعد جزءا مهما من العدوان
الروسي على اوكرانيا لذا فان الامن مترابط
وبالتالي فانما يحدث هنا مهم ايضا لحلف
شمال الاطلسي وما يحدث في اوروبا مهم
لاسيا البلدان التي تؤمن بالحريه
والديمقراطيه يجب ان تساعد بعضها البعض
لاننا نرى ان القوه لاستبداديه تقترب اكثر
الاتحاد يعتقد ان امتداد اوكرانيا بال
باقي الغربيه ليس تصعيدا للصراع واعتبر في
افادته الصحفيه ان ما يحدث هو رد على
التصعيد من جانب روسيا وقال اننا نوفر
اموالا لاوكرانيا للحمايه وصن واصل هذا
الدعم لطالما كان ذلك ضروريا
من جانبه قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي
سناء قال ان بريطانيا يجب ان تكون فخوره
بقياده العالم في دعم اوكرانيا ومواجهه
العدوان الروسي مضيفا ان لندن كانت اول
دوله تفعل ذلك ما ادى الى تحرك دولي ودول
اخرى كبرى كالمانيا وامريكا معرضا عن عمله
في تحقيق اوكرانيا المزيد من التقدم ضد
روسيا خلال الجزء الاول من هذا العام
مع تصعيد التوترات بين موسكو من جهه
والغرب من جهه اخرى تضل نقطه تحول
الرئيسيه في مائده قرر الطرفان الدخول في
صراع مباشر لكن هل موسكو تفكر في الامر
ربما ذكره رئيس الوزراء البريطاني السابق
برج جونسون قد يشير الى ذلك العام الماضي
وجد جنس نفسه ضحيه تهديد مزعوم من الرئيس
الروسي بلادي ماركوتن ففي مكالمه هاتفيه
استثنائيه
ونبره صوت هادئه اخبر الرئيس الروسي
جونسون انه لا يريد ان يؤذيه لكنه تابع ان
ضربه صاروخيه بامكانها ان تسقطه وفي غضون
دقائق كانت هذه الكلمات بوتن منذ عام
والتي ظلت تطارد جنسا وبدا انه لم يتمكن
من نسيانها وفي حديث له مع هيئه الاذاعه
البريطانيه ضمن وثائقي جديد قال جنسن ان
تعليقات بوتن التي وصفها بالدنيا جاءت بعد
تهديده بفرض عقوبات اشد موسكو نتيجه حرب
اوكرانيا يكشف الوثائقي بعنوان بوتن ضد
الغرب عن لحظه اخرى مثيره للاهتمام
استذكرها وزير الدفاع البرتغنيه بن ويلز
الذي قال ان نظيره الروسيسور جيشيكو اخبره
خلال زيارته لموسكو ان الشعب الاوكراني لن
يرد في حاله تعرضه لهجوم روسيا
لا اريد ان اذيك لكن بصاروخ سيستغرق الامر
دقيقه واحده فقط او شيئا من هذا القبيل
ومع محاولتي لحمله على التفاوض قال بوريس
انت تقول ان اوكرانيا لن تنضم الى الناتو
في اي وقت قريب ثم قال ما هو الوقت القريب
الذي تقصده وقلت حسنا لن تنضم الى النيه
حتى في المستقبل وانت تعلم ذلك جيدا
واحاول التطورات الميدانيه تتصاعد وتيره
المعارك في مقاطعه دونتس شرقي اوكرانيا
وسطى تقدم للقوات الروسيه في محاور
اوبلدار جنوب المقاطعه وفي بخموت شمالا
فيما تحاول كيف صدق قوات بقدر عبر تعزيز
الدفاعاتها خوفا من سقوطها كما حدث من قبل
في سوليدار
الشمالي من مقاطعه دانيس حيث مازالت قوات
بانر تطوق مدينه باخبط من النواحي
الشماليه والجنوبيه والشرقيه وتحاول
اقتحام المدينه من المحور الجنوبي قتال
شوارع في ذلك المحور بالفعل تشير مصادر
ايضا الى استقدام الجيش الاوكراني لاعداد
كبيره من الجنود والاليات العسكريه وتاسيس
قاعده عسكريه غرب مدينه باخمط في منطقه او
مدينه
من الجيش الاوكراني الانسحاب من مدينه
بلاجاباتنا شمال المقاطعه حيث اعلنت قوات
بان سيطرتها على هذه البلده معارك ساخنه
وضاريه في المحور الناري المثلث الناري
بين لوجان
الهجمات المتبادله ما بين الجيشين
الاوكراني والروسي وتشير المصادر الى
استقدام حشود كبيره من الجيش الاوكراني
واليات في ذلك المحور من اجل التقدم حيث
تمركز الجيش الروسي
هذا وسبعه سلطات الايرانيه القائمه
بالاعمال الاوكراني في طهران وذلك طبعا
على خلفيه تصريحات صادر عن بلاده بشان
هجوم بطائرات مسيره استهدفه منشاه عسكريه
باقليم اصفهان وفقا وكاله تسنيم
الايرانيات ربط احد كبار مساعدي الرئيس
الاوكراني الحادثه بالحرب في اوكرانيا
مؤكدا وجود علاقه مباشره بينهما
من كيف ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا بك حذيفه دعنا نبدا بالتطورات
الميدانيه
مساء الخير ميسون يعني في الحقيقه الان
الوضع الميداني مستعر في باخ متحديدا في
تحاول القوات الروسيه اكمال عمليه الحصار
التي تحاول الوصول اليها لهذه المدينه
وقطع الطرق الامداد للقوات المقاتله في
مدينه باخبط تقول القوات القوات
الاوكرانيه وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان
الوضع ما زال تحت السيطره في باخم لا توجد
اي نيه للانسحاب من هذه المدينه القوات
يعني اتصل الامدادات بشكل مستمر بشكل دوري
الى القوات في هذه المنطقه همم طبعا ايضا
المحاور الساخنه دار وهنا تقول وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه
تحاول ان اا يعني همم تحاول ان تنظر كيف
وضع الدفاع في هذه المنطقه وهذا ليس هو
الهجوم الاساسي وانما هي تحاول ان تصرف
نظر القوات الاوكرانيه عن الهدف الاساسي
للقوات الروسيه في منطقه باخره اما في
كوبرزك وفي الصفاتف هناك القتال يدور ما
زال والقوات الاوكرانيه تقول انها هي التي
تحقق تقدم خلاف ذلك طبعا في الجنوب وفي
غيره القتال بالمدفعيه هنالك عمليات قسم
متبادله بين الجانبين نفذت القوات الروسيه
3 ضربات جويه وثلاثه وقامت ايضا بتنفيذ
بثلاثه ضربات صاروخيه و 44
قليل الاستدعاء القائم بالاعمال الاوكراني
من قبل همم طهران بسبب تصريحات المتعلقه
باستهداف اصفهان همم ردود الفعل فيك
نعم يعني اولا دعينا نسمي المسؤول
الاوكراني الذي يتحدث عنه الخبر بشكل عام
ااا في مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني هو ميخائيل
بودلاك مستشار الرئيس
الياسكي تحدثت اليه قبل قليل وسالت عن
التعليق الذي قام به طبعا التعليق هو
منشور هو قام باعاده تغريد تغريده كان قد
نشرها سابقا في الرابع والعشرين من ديسمبر
من العام الماضي التغريده الاولى كانت
تتحدث عن انه يجب على الغرب على الشركاء
ان يتخلوا عن اسلوب همم يعني همم
المفاوضات مع الجانبه نعم مع الجانب
الايراني وايضا التخلي عن همم مساله
العقوبات والتوجه مباشره لتنفيذ ضربات
قاسيه تستهدف المنتجين وتستهدف الموردين
كذلك للاسلحه الاتحاد الروسي هذه التغريده
وفي هذه المره قال ان الحرب يعني هو كلام
عام ليس فيه شيء دقيق وليس فيه شيء موجهه
هذه
حرب هي هائله توقيتهم حذيفه طبعا قال ان
هذه حرب
هذا صحيح طبعا ميسون ان التوقيت هو يوحي
بان هنالك ربط بين الامور قد يكون طبعا
ميخائيل بودلك قصد ذلك بشكل واضح ويتحدث
عن الانفجار في في دوله ايران قال ان هذا
الانفجار وكذلك 1,000 كلم من الحدود ومن
الخنادق وايضا هنالك كثير من المواطنين
الروس الذين يهربون من التعبئه كل ذلك
جلبته هذه الحرب هذا هو ملخص الحديث طبعا
هنا كما يقول يعني كما ينظر اليه المحل
لانه هنالك اشاره واضحه الى ان هذا الامر
متعلق بالحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا او
الحرب في اوكرانيا هو طبعا مكتب مخالفه
يعني هنالك حديث مباشر حول تعليق مباشره
حول ما حدث في ايران
وهذا يضعنا بتساؤل مهم همم لم يرد ان يربط
هذا بذاك هل همم يمكن ان نقرا بان هناك في
محاوله للتهدئه همم خطابيا على الاقل ام
ماذا
يعني بالطبع لا طبعا ميخائيل بدلاكو هو
معروف انه اكثر المستشارين الذين يتحدثون
بلهجه فيها كثير من اداء من الغضب وفيها
كثير من الرغبه
بالاستعاده السيطره بالقوه وان الاتحاد
الروسي يجب عليه ان ينسحب من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المعترف بها لذلك يعني لا توجد
مؤشرات الى اي حديث همم تهدئه هنا همم
القياده الاوكرانيه بشكل عام في تصريحاتها
عندما ننظر اليها نجد انهم اصبحوا مقتنعين
وياسوا تمام من اي عمليات تفاوض وان يمكن
لاي عمليات سلام ان تنهي هذه الحربهم الان
يعولون فقط على مزيد من الاسلحه ويعاولون
على الجيش الاوكراني انه ان ان يستطيع
استعاده الاراضي وبعد ان يصل الى الحدود
المعترف بها عام 1901 عندها يقولون ان
الاتحاد الروسي يمكن ان يجلس يعني التفاوض
بشان اي عمليه
التي وصلت الان الى طائرات من خلال بولندا
اليس كذلك
نعم هذا صحيح الان هذا هو هدف استراتيجي
بالنسبه لوزاره الخارجيه ووزاره الدفاع
ولمكتب الرئيس الاوكراني وهذا نرصده من
خلال التصريحات من الرئيس الاوكراني في
نادي نفسه من وزير الدفاع نفسه ومن ترك
وليفا وزير الخارجيه الذين وضعوا هذا
الامر كهدف للوصول اليه خاصه في اجتماع
اينشتاين القادم في الشهر المقبل وسوف
تذهب اوكرانيا باجين واضحه همم تحمل طلبات
بي اف 16 طائرات المقاتله وكذلك بالصواريخ
بعيده المدى ويقولون انه من خلال هذه
الاسلحه طبعا نفس ال 16 مشهوره بانها يمكن
ان تنفذ عمليات متعدده على القوات
الاخرانيه السلاح الجوي الاوكراني الان
لديه اس اربعه سو 24
هذه الطائرات كلهم منها تؤدي عمليات
مختلفه عن الاخرى لكن افسد تتحشر تجمع كل
هذه العمليات تستطيع القوات الاوكرانيه ان
تنفذ عمليات في العمق لضرب مخازن ذخيره
وقطع الطرق الاستراتيجيه وقطع الامدادات
عن القوات الروسيه لذلك هم يرغبون في
الحصول عليها كما انهم يرغبون في الاسلحه
بعيده المدى لانهم الان لديهم فقط
المدفعيه التي ابعد ما يمكن ان تصل اليه
هو 80 كم وهو يعني ما لا يمكنهم منه الضرب
اي مخازن او اي قواعد عسكريه للروس في
الاردن
[تصفيق]
في اوكرانيا في طريقها للتوسع والانتقال
الى حرب مدمره ويعزون السبب للبدء بوصول
اسلحه غربيه ثقيله الى اوكرانيا الدعم
الغربي نقل الاخيره من الدفاعي الى الهجوم
نحو عشرات الدبابات يتامل الغرب ان تغير
وضع القوات الاخرانيه على الارض بشكل
جذريا لصالحها الا ان موسكو بتوقعات
معاكسه مؤكده ان الدبابات الغربيه لن تغير
المعادله على الارض لا تقتصر الحزمه
الجديده من الاسلحه على دبابات اليوبارز
بل انتقلت للمساعده الى المستوى اخر من
الدعم
بالمدرعات من طراز براد
ومضادات الالغام لتوهل في مناطق السيطره
الروس اسلحه هجوميه بام
ومقابل كل سلاح غربي هجومي تضع روسيا
سلاحا رادعا ربما لا يقل شده عن نظيره
وكان الرد الروسي على قرار الاسلحه
الجديده
وبلا من الصواريخ على مدن اوكرانيه ووعدا
بادخال اسلحه اقوى الى ساحه الحرب
انيه
خلال الربيع منتهيه فرصه ان روسيا تستجمع
قواها وتجدد امداداتها من الدخيره والسلاح
يتوقع ان يتخذ الرئيس الروسي بلادي مير
بوتين خطوه للسباقيه قبل حزمه المساعدات
العسكريه ويشونه هجوما جديدا على اوكرانيا
في فبراير القادم بحسب ما نشرته
ان ياتون الحرب ستكون في ذروتها ولا ربما
ستمتد حمامها لدول الجوار ايضا ايضا عمر
العربيه
اكادي وزير الخارجيه المغربيه ناصر بوريطه
خلال مؤتمر صحفي مع رئيس البعثه الاماميه
للدعم في ليبيا اكد ان المغرب مع وحده
ليبيا ومع سيادتها مشيرا الى ان بلاده ضد
كل التدخلات الخارجيه في ليبيا ومع الحل
الليبي الليبي برعايه الامميه
[موسيقى]
وسيادتها الوطنيه
خصوص التحضيرات لاجراء الانتخابات كما ان
هناك ايضا عراقيل نامو ان يحل ليبيون
سريعا وذلك تحت مظله الامم المتحده
والمبادرات الاقليميه الاخرى التي من
شانها ان تسهم في تجاوز الخلافات حول
النقاط العالقه
الامميه في ليبيا عبد الله باتيلي دعا
الليبيين الى الجلوس على طاوله الحوار
بهدف التوصل الى اتفاق ليبي ليبيا الاسماء
الى التباحث والجلوس حول الطاوله الحوار
بهدف التواصل الى اتفاق الليبيين ليبي
نعملوا الى جانب المجتمع الدولي وشركائنا
في المغرب على انهائه هذه المعضله ونمل من
الجميع ان يقوم بدوره ونحنون نسير في طريق
واحد لحال حاله الازمه الليبيه
الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
منظمه الصحه العالميه تحذر من النجائحه
كورونا لا تزال حال الطوارئ عالميه وتثير
القلق
له
وزير الخارجيه الباكستاني قال ان بلاده
تقدر العلاقات مع روسيا والولايات المتحده
واوروبا وبشكل متساوي مؤكدا انها ستظل
الصوت المؤيد للسلام والحوار في المجتمع
الدوله
تسهيل الاجراءات حيث ستسمح هذه التاشيرات
تاشيره المرور بالدخول الى السعوديه واداء
العمره والتنقل في كافه المناطق اضافه
الوزاره ان القرار يدخل حيز التنفيذ بدءا
من اليوم وذلك عبر التقدم بطلب الزياره
جوا عبر منصات الخطوط الجويه السعوديه
وطيران ناس وسيتم معالجه الطلبات واصدار
التاشيرات بشكل فوري الخارجيه السعوديه
اكدت ان تاشيره مجانيه وتتيح لحاملها
لاقامه في المملكه لاربعه ايام فقط
كشفت مصادر للعربيه عن تجدد القصف اليوم
على الحدود العراقيه السوريه المصادر قالت
ان ضربتين جويتين استهدفتان مكانا في
منطقه البوكمال من الجانب السوري المصادر
اضافت ان القصف كان بالقرب من منفذ القائم
الحدودي تحديدا مخفر المحسن الذي تتواجد
فيه قوته حرس الحدود العراقيه يحدث هذا في
وقت استهدفت فيه طائرات مجهوله قافله
تابعه لميليشيا ايرانيه كانت في طريقها من
العراق الى سوريا وفق ما ذكر المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان القصف تسبب في مقتل
سبعه اشخاص غير سوريين وتدمير الشاحنات
بالكامل
اعلنت المعارضه التركيه عما سميته بوثيقه
السياسات المشتركه لاداره مرحله ما بعد
الانتخابات في حال وصولها الى السلطه
وتضمن الوثيقه عاده النظام البرلماني بدلا
من النظام الرئاسه المعمول به حاليا كما
دعت الوثيقه الى ان تكون مده ولايه الرئيس
سبع سنوات غير قابله للتجديد كما من
المقرر ان تحصر الوثيقه سلطه اغلاق
الاحزاب السياسيه بيد البرلمان
على كل ان مشاهدينا نشير الى العاجل
الخارجيه الايرانيه تتحدث ان تصريحات
مستشار رئيس الاوكراني حول هجوم اصفهان هي
عدائيه طبعا تاتي هذه التصريحات بعد ان
كانت طهران قد استدعت القائم بالاعمال
الاوكراني وذلك على خلفيه تصريحات
مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني والتي قال فيها
بان ما يحدث من استهدافات لايران بصوره
عامه كما افاد في بيان له ردا على سؤال
لمراسلنا فان ذلك بسبب مشاركه ايران بما
يحدث في اوكرانيا بمعنى اخر ان علاقه او
ما قرات من انه علاقه ما حدث واستهداف
اصفهان همم هو مباشر ومرتبط مباشره بما
يحدث في اوكرانيا والدور الذي تلعبه ايران
في تسيير مسيرات لروسيا تستخدم في الحرب
في اوكرانيا او العمليه العسكريه هناك
احنا كل ما عود الان الى الميثاق وثيقه
السياسات المشتركه التي عرضتها المعارضه
للتحضير لمرحله ما بعد اردوغان اذا ما
نجحت في الانتخابات معنا من انقره مراسل
العربيه زيدان زنجلو خبرنا اكثر عن هذه
الوثيقه زيدان
هي لمرحله ما بعد الانتخابات في حال وصلت
المعارضه الى السلطه هذه الوثيقه تنظم عمل
المؤسسات الحكوميه والوزرات وهي خطه عمل
المعارضه في جميع المؤسسات تقريبا هذه
الوثيقه تتالف من تسعه ابواب هذه ابواب
التسعه مقسمه الى 75 عنوان وبالمجمل
الوثيقه تتضمن
2500 باند هي مجمل مقترحات او عود
المعارضه في حال وصلت الى السلطه طبعا
بالدرجه الاولى تركز الوثيقه على اصلاح
النظام السياسي
وكشرت اساسي العوده الى النظام البرلماني
بدلا من النظام الرئاسي الحالي الذي يعطي
الرئيس صلاحيات واسعه همم طبعا الوثيقه
تحدث شروط العوده والمرحله الانتقاليه
التي تتضمنها هذه العوده وما يجب ان يتم
من تعديلات سواء في عمل
اا حكومه او نشاطات الرئيس صلاحيات الرئيس
هناك حد من صلاحيات الرئيس وايضا فصل لبعض
المؤسسات والجهات التابعه مباشره للرئاسه
على سبيل المثال الحصر صندوق الثروه
السيادي الذي يدفع مباشره الى رئاسه
الجمهوريه سيتم الغاء هذا الصندوق او فصله
عن الرئيس ايضا سيكون هناك صلاحيات اوسع
للبرلمان همم سيكون ايضا صلاحيات اوسع
لمجلس الوزراء ورئيس الوزراء هذا بالنسبه
تشريعات عديده في مخصص النظام همم
كامل من ضمن ال الاولويات انقلاب كامل عن
على كل ما ادخله همم الرئيس همم رجب طيب
اردوغان او
تمريره بخلال حكمه اليس كذلك
نعم نعم ليس الموضوع يقتصر فقط على موضوع
اصلاح النظام السياسي والعوده الى النظام
البرلمان بل ايضا مما لفت نظري عندما حضرت
الاجتماع اليوم همم الغاء بعض المؤسسات
التي انشاها اردوغان ومثلا على سبيل
المثال على الحصر المجمع الرئاسي هنا في
انقره قررت المعارضه في حال وصلت الى
السلطه الغاء هذا المجمع والعوده الى قصه
شانكا القديم القصر الرئاسي على سبيل
المثال للحصر همم مطار اتاتورك القديم
الذي اعلن عنه اردوغان انه سيكون حديقه
وطنيه تم همم في حال وصلت المعارضه سيتم
اعاده تشغيله مجددا كما طاهر طبعا هذا
الموضوع يعني تحدث كما ذكرت انقلاب كامل
ليس فقط على صعيد ايضا الانظمه والقوانين
ونظام الحكم ايضا على همم حتى يشمل بعض
المؤسسات والانجاز او ما نتحدث عن انجازات
المشاريع التي همم انشاها اردوغان في همم
كان انقر او اسطنبول او عديد المدن لذلك
همم نعود الوثيقه من ضمن المحاور الاساسيه
والهمم مهمه التي ركز عليها موضوع
الاقتصاد اصلاح الاقتصاد تعاهدت المعارضه
في حال وصلت الى السلطه بانها ستعود او
ستخفض التضخم الى خانه الاحاد اي الى
مرتبه واحده خلال سنتين ايضا تعاهدت
المعارضه بتوفير اكثر
من خمس سنوات وايضا مكافحه
ايضا برنامج لمكافحه هجره الادمغه وعوده
الكفاءات التي غادرت ايضا هنا في مجال
الحقوق والحريات العامه كان هناك همم
تركيز على موضوع حريه الصحافه حقوق
الانسان وايضا كان هناك اولويه وبنت كامل
فيما يخص حقوق المراه ومن ضمن الحديث اا
هناك حديث عن اعاده تركي او عدد تركيا
مجددا الى اتفاقيه اسطنبول
طيب على كلن يبدو انه زيدان لا يسمعني على
كل شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المعلومات كنا
نود ان نعرف ان كان هناك اسم
للترشح من قبل المعارضه وبالمقابل ردود
الفعل ولكن ربما في نشرات اخرى مراسل
العربيه زيدان زين كلو من انقر شكرا جزيلا
لك
ايضا قال وزير الخارجيه التركي مولود شاوش
اوغلو انها بامكان بلاده تقييم طلبات
انضمام فنلندا والسويد الى النت بشكل
منفصل اذا ما قرر الحفظ ذلك
والسويديه بشكل منفصل اذا اتخذ النيته
وتلك الدول قرارا بشان ذلك يقول رئيسنا
انه يمكن ان يكون هناك تقييم منفصل
لفنلندا عن السويد لكن في البدايه يتعين
على النيته وتلك الدول اتخاذ قرارا بهذا
الشان
وكان وزير الخارجيه الفن الانديه قال ان
امنه بلاده من امن السويد وان البلدين
يريدان الانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي معا
جاء ذلك خلال مؤتمر صحفي رد فيه رئيس
الدبلوماسيه الفنلنديه على تعليقات الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان التي سمعناها
الوزير قال ان رغبه فنلندا كانت ولا تزال
هي الانضمام الى الناتو مع السويد
اشار الكرملين الى اجراء الرئيس الروسي
بلادي ميرفت ان اتصالا هاتفيه النبي ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان بحث
خلاله العلاقات بين البلدين حسب بيان
الكرملين ناقش الرئيس بوتين مع الامير
محمد بن سلمان ناقشات تعاون في التجاره
والطاقه كما بحثا استقرار اسواق النفط
والتعاون في ايطاليا
قالت منظمه الصحه العالميه انه فايروس
ماذا لا يعتبر حاله الطوارئ صحيه عامه على
المستوى الدولي عبرت المنظمه عن قلقها من
الخطر الذي مازال يشكله الفايروس على حياه
البشر
ده كوميدي
19 لا يزال حاله طوارئ صحيه عالميه وانا
اوافق على ذلك مع دخولنا العام الرابع
للوباء ليس هناك شك في اننا في وضع افضل
بكثير الان مما كنا عليه قبل عام عندما
كانت موجته ومكرون في ذروتها
عن استعداد بكين للعمل وذلك باقصى حد من
اجل اعاده توحيد السلمي للجزيره تايوان
الى الصين مشدده على ان حل قضيه تايوان
مساله تخص الشعب الصيني يجب ان يقررها
الصينيون انفسهم متابعه
اولا اود ان اقول ان تايوان جزء من الصين
مساله تخص الشعب الصيني ويجب ان يقرره
الصينيون انفسهم نحن على استعداد للعمل
باقصى قدر من الاخلاص وبذل اقصى الجهود
السعي من اجل اعاده التوحيد السلميه لكننا
لن نعيدها بالتخلي عن استخدام القوه
ونحتفظ بخيار اتخاذ جميع الاجراءات
اللازمه
شكرا ديما اشار تقرير لوكاله بلومبيرغ الى
نيه كل من روسيا وكوريا الشماليه لعقد
صفقات سلاح تحاول من خلالها موسكو زياده
مخزونها العسكري في حربها على اوكرانيا من
ناحيه وتتمكن بيونغ يونغ من الخروج من
ازمتها الاقتصاديه من ناحيه اخرى
مع اوكرانيا
حاجه للخروج من نفق ركود اقتصادي كلمه
السر في حل الازمتين صفقات السلاح فوفقا
لتقرير لوكاله بلومبرج وجد الطرفين مخرجا
لحل ازماتهما بعقد المزيد من صفقات السلاح
التي توفر دخلا لكوريا الشماليه المعزوله
اقتصاديا ومخزونا عسكريا لروسيا
وفقا لوكاله بلومبرج تحظى بيونج يونج
بتنوع في مخزون سلاحها ملائم الاحتياجات
روسيا من بينها مدفعيه القرن العشرين
البدائيه الموجوده على الخطوط الاماميه
الروسيه امام اوكرانيا كما تمتلك ترسانه
للذخيره المدفعيه تحتوي على اكثر من
21,600 قطعه الى جانب قذائف مدفعيه 122
ملليمتر
و152 ملليمتر جميعها تلاقي مراقبات موسكو
تشيروا التقارير الى ان حجم الصفقات
العسكريه بين موسكو وبيونغ يونج قد تبلغ
320 مليون دولار امريكي ما قد يضيفوا
واحدا في المئه الى اجمالي الناتج المحلي
لكوريا الشماليه لكن موسكو قد تفضل تقييم
جوده بعض الاسلحه قبل الالتزام بعمليه
شراء كبيره
لم يعد نقل السلاح من كوريا الشماليه الى
روسيا يشكل هاجسا فلم تعد هناك حاجه
للمرور عبر دوله ثالثه ووفقا لموقعه انه
وصلتي 8 مستندا لصور عبر الاقمار الصناعيه
فان حركه التجاره عبر خط السكك الحديديه
الوحيد بينهما استئنفه التجاره عليه اواخر
العام الماضي دعم متبادل بين موسكو وبيونغ
يونج لكنه تحت مجهر واشنطن الرافضه له
هناك ادله على ان مجموعه فاجنر وهي منظمه
شبه عسكريه تشارك بشده في جهود السيطره
على مدينه باخم موت كانت تتلقى شاحنات
ومعدات من كوريا الشماليه تحذير امريكي
تواكبه تحركات لها في كوريا الجنوبيه وقد
يشعل الصراع بين دعم الكوريتين وفق تصريح
الخارجيه الروسيه نشر الاسلحه النوويه
الامريكيه في كوريا الجنوبيه المحتمل
سيؤدي الى عواقب غير حميده وستضطر
حاله تحققي هذا السيناريو الى اخذ الامر
في الاعتبار على صعيد تخطيطها الدفاعي
في الواجهه صراع روسي الاوكراني وفي
خلفيته تصعيد متواصل بين حلفاء كل جانب
كانت اخر حلقاته تحالف بيونغيانغ موسكو
العسكري الاقتصادي في مواجهه تحالف واشنط
صول الضغط والرافدي لهذا التعاون على
السمان العربيه
وايضا المزيد من الاخبار والتحليلات تابع
موقعنا العربيه
نتوقع ان يظهر اتمنى ان يظهر
على كل شكرا للمتابعه وصلنا الى نهايه
الخامسه ونلتقي في نشرات لاحقا شكرا
مشاهديننا ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]